we feel so down at that moment
because we don't know where we can go
[Music]
hong kong has around 340 000 foreign
domestic workers often referred to as
helpers this 31 year old who asked us
not to use her real name is one of them
after testing positive for kovit 19 her
employer refused to let her quarantine
at home effectively leaving her homeless
i thought the hospital will help us
on our case but no one they refused us
they shot with us they didn't help us so
hard for me
without food or warm clothes bj spent a
cold night camped outside a hospital
before being moved to a shelter the next
day her case is not unique
since the past one week we've seen an
exponential rise in the cases
help is supporting over 100 domestic
workers uh with with either safe shelter
or
with food water medical supplies and
other basic necessities
roughly 10 percent of households in hong
kong employ a helper and legally they
must live in their employers homes
scores with kovit have been evicted or
sacked by employers who don't want the
virus in their households according to
local rights groups
they are in a very desperate situation
they feel very sick but at the same time
the worries
they worry more about
where should we go
is there any places to stay the labor
department issued a statement saying
employers should not dismiss foreign
domestic helpers who have contracted
kovit-19
it could lead to prosecution and a fine
of up to 12
800 u.s dollars
foreign domestic helpers have also been
hard hit by fines for breaching the
two-person gathering limits the fines
can be as much as twice a helper's
monthly wage
despite bj's ordeal she remains hopeful
my employer told me they are waiting for
me
so i need to do a three times swap this
if they are negative so i can go back to
them in the house
i need to do my best to support my son
and give the peace that i can give as a
mother to my son
[Music]
you